يتنحى جاك دورسي ، المؤسس المشارك والمدير التنفيذي المثير للجدل ،
عن مهامه التنفيذية
في تويتر ، على الرغم من أنه من المتوقع
أن يظل في منصب الرئيس التنفيذي لشركته الأخرى
التي تُعرف باسم سكوير والتي تعد
لاعبًا رئيسيًا في مجال المدفوعات الرقمية
تم اتهام دورسي مثل غيره من المديرين التنفيذيين لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بعدم القيام
بما يكفي للسيطرة على انتشار
المعلومات المضللة على منصته ،
وبول ومونيكا في نيويورك حسنًا ،
فلا يمكن أن يكون جاك دورسي
مريحًا لرؤية الأسهم في بلاده في
ارتفعت شركته cu بمقدار 10
في هذه الأخبار ، أعني أن الكثير من الناس يعرفون أن
هذا كان قادمًا ،
فلماذا الآن ولماذا رد فعل
المستثمرين بول
نعم أعتقد أن المستثمرين بيكي كانوا
يطالبون بنوع من التغيير لفترة من
الوقت الآن  كما ذكرت ، كان جاك دورسي
يدير كلاً من Twitter و Square
وقد أثار حيرة الكثير من الناس حول
كيفية إدارته بفعالية
لشركتي
التكنولوجيا الرائدتين المتداولتين علنًا بشكل
فعال  لايوجد الكثير من المساعدة
حتى
الآن بعد أن نقل
زمام الأمور إلى كبير مسؤولي التكنولوجيا في
Twitter parag agrawal أعتقد أن
هذه علامة على أن Twitter يدرك
أنه يجب عليه مضاعفة التكنولوجيا
لمحاربة بعض أه تعرف  جهات فاعلة سيئة
على هذه المنصة التي
ذكرتها ، وأعتقد أن وجود أشياء مثل
التعلم الآلي والتطورات التكنولوجية الكبيرة الأخرى
آمل أن
تفعل ذلك على تويتر وأعتقد أن المستثمرين
سيجدون أن لديك
شخصًا أكثر
ذكاءً من الناحية التكنولوجية من ربما يكون خبيرًا في وسائل الإعلام يدير
هذا  شركة